[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zur pressekonferenz
mit verteidigungsministerin klaudia
tanner mit dem leiter der militär des
militärischen dienstes im
verteidigungsministeriums oberst dr
michael krainer und dem kommandanten der
hunde zentrums in kaisersteinbruch
oberst otto kopitzsch und ich darf die
frau verteidigungsministerin ersuchen zu
beginnen dankeschön sehr geehrter herr
oberst cockpit sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe medienvertreterinnen und
-vertreter die korona pandemie hat uns
seit mittlerweile eineinhalb beinahe
zwei jahren fest im griff das zeigen
auch die jetzt wieder steigenden zahlen
mittlerweile gibt es genügend test und
impf angebote um das virus in schach zu
halten ich kann aber nicht eine
pressekonferenz zu beginnen ohne den
appell an sie alle zu richten bitte
nutzen sie diese angebote lassen sie
sich impfen und regelmäßig testen damit
wir auch weiterhin das virus im zaum
halten können von anbeginn an der korona
pandemie haben unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten aber auch die zivilbediensteten
des bundesheeres stets bewiesen dass sie
immer für uns da sind ein verlässlicher
partner in ein
krisensituationen von der
katastrophenhilfe zum grenzschutz im
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz
botschafts bewachung oder auch massen
testungen gerade am heutigen tag gedenkt
tag ist die botschafts bewachung hier
auch im zentrum oder auch der einsatz im
katastrophengebiet in reichenau an der
rax unser bundesheer hat immer wieder
gezeigt wie flexibel wie vielfältig und
wie professionell
reagiert und es freut mich heute
wirklich sehr
dass wir auch im bereich der forschung
sagen können ja unsere experten unsere
expertinnen die können sich sehen lassen
es war vor mehr als einem jahr als unser
militär 100 zentrum einen neuen ansatz
probiert hat und ein jahr lang getestet
hat nämlich die ausbildung zum corona
spürhund und dazu haben wir unsere erste
carola spürhunde in fantasy forever vom
c3 blick so heißt sie ganz korrekte hier
auch neben uns sitzt
vorgestellt es war eine mehr als
sechsmonatige ausbildung insbesondere
mit hilfe von luftröhren in denen
geruchsmoleküle eines carola virus
enthalten waren unter so wurde unsere
schäferhündin auf den geruch
konditioniert nach der grundausbildung
startete unser bundesheer verschiedenste
kooperationen um dann diese ausbildung
auch voranzutreiben dazu gehörte auch
die kooperation der zusammenarbeit mit
unserem amt für rüstungs und wehrtechnik
dass er ganz besonders eingesetzt war
ihm der krise dann mit dem
sanitätszentrum süd mit dem
landeskrankenhaus graz sowie dem
landesklinikum in stockerau die unsere
hundestaffel in der erprobungsphase auch
mit infizierten masken proben stark
unterstützt haben und sehr geehrte damen
und herren ich glaube der eine oder
andere von ihnen war auch dabei es war
noch die wiener sängerknaben die dieses
projekt ganz besonders unterstützt haben
gebrauchte masken die uns zur verfügung
gestellt worden sind und im weiteren
training konnten dann die suchergebnisse
der hunde mit den ergebnissen der
medizinischen tests verglichen werden
sagt sie auch noch einmal zum glück war
es damals so dass die ergebnisse jungen
sänger alle negativ waren was wissen wir
schon länger wir wissen schon länger
dass unsere diensthunde verschiedene
stoffe aufspüren können das ist er
wahrlich nichts neues aber ich glaube
dass ich schon etwas ganz besonderes
dass wir hier geschafft haben dass es
neben einem kampfmittel spürhund
ebenfalls suchtmittel spürhunde gibt die
sprengstoffe oder suchtgifte erkennen
erkennen können aber das ist schon etwas
herausragendes mit unserer corona spiel
in unserer fans dass sie vor wenn man
daran denkt dass unsere beiden es sind
mittlerweile zwei ausgebildeten hunde
über 3000 proben erschnüffelt haben mit
einer erfolgsquote die weit über 80
prozent
liegt dann bin ich am heutigen tag stolz
möchte mich bei den beiden herren
bedanken rechts und links an meiner
seite die wirklich ein besonderes know
how bewiesen haben die unsere feinen
spürnasen darauf trainiert haben ein
virus wie mit 19 zu erschnüffeln die
frage also kunde ein virus wie eine
corona infektion beispielsweise
erschnüffeln können wie können wir heute
nach abschluss des berichtes eindeutig
mit ja
beantworten ich glaube dass diese
besondere ausbildung unserer koroma
spüren denn wirklich sehr erfolgreicher
beitragen weiterer erfolgreicher beitrag
unseres series ist im kampf gegen das
virus und auch für pandemische
entwicklungen in der zukunft genutzt und
gewertet werden kann es sind
entsprechende
projekte auch in vorbereitung auf der
europäischen ebene und auch aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht hat ohne
zweifel diese erprobung international
für aufsehen in den fachkreisen gesorgt
aber dazu gibt es dann noch näheres ein
wichtiger grundstein würde ich sagen für
die wissenschaftliche forschung und da
gibt es auch absichtserklärungen bereits
mittel stadt leipzig die ende september
bereits ihr interesse an einer
kooperation und wissenschaftlichen
unterstützung auch bekundet hat das ist
bereits gestartet worden sie sehen also
sehr geehrte damen und herren unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten des militär 100
zentrums haben unglaublich viel
vorangebracht im letzten jahr und ich
bin wirklich sehr sehr stolz darauf was
hier voran gebracht worden ist
vielleicht mit der ein oder an
kooperation in der zukunft wird es
möglich werden diese spürhunde
ausbildung auch international zu teilen
ich bin dann schon gespannt welche neuen
erkenntnisse opfers topitsch auch noch
über den weiteren verlauf erzählen wird
über die ausbildung über die ergebnisse
auch des berichtes und herr oberst
keiner wird dann auch nochmals auf die
kooperationen eingehen die wir gemeinsam
mit dem militär hundezentrum war in
zukunft staaten wollen nicht kann an
dieser stelle nur sagen ich bin wirklich
sehr stolz auf unsere experten des
hauses in zusammenhang mit dieser
besonderen ausbildung
herzlichen dank bitte herr oberst
kopitzsch dankeschön das sehr geehrte
frau bundesminister verehrte damen und
herren
ich habe hier die möglichkeit ihnen ein
bisschen einen einblick in diese
erprobung zu geben wir haben
mittlerweile von mehr als einem jahr
begonnen
hunde für eine für das aufspüren von
viren dem konkreten das kann ohne virus
auszubilden diese erprobung war aber ein
ein vorgang mit offenem ausgang das hat
man am anfang an überhaupt nicht gewusst
und zu der zeit wo wir begonnen haben
hatte ich ja auch nicht diese berühmten
schnell da ist gegeben und auch kein
test verfahren wie wir es heute nach
fast
eineinhalb jahren vorliegen haben das
heißt
für uns war es hier entsprechend auch
wichtig von anfang an für zukünftige
bedrohungen
möglicherweise
den einsatz von hunden hier zu überlegen
und vier vorzusehen und das ist am ende
dieser erprobung jetzt in dem bericht
eindeutig auch wie die frau
bundesminister gesagt hat auch mit ja zu
beantworten
ich darf kurz auf das eingehen was wir
jetzt in zukunft hier noch vorhaben und
planen ich möchte aber auch für viele
die den einblick ins militär nicht zu
haben möchte ich auch sagen das militär
und dezent haben dass diese ausbildung
an macht ist eine bildungseinrichtung
wir sind eine schule ist kein einzelfall
der überall flächendeckende meinte zu
seiner schule die eben die hunde des
österreichischen bundesheeres
österreichweit ausbildet sind natürlich
nicht nur spürhunde sondern auch
schutzhunde und mögliche das erprobungs
ergebnis ist insofern von von glaube
hoher relevanz und das wird sie dann vor
allem wenn die wissenschaftliche studie
publiziert wird
bestätigen und ich glaube dass es hier
sehr viel internationales echo auch
geben wird vor allem weil wir jetzt
bereits ohne dass diese studie in der
öffentlichkeit publiziert wurde schon
anfragen aus deutschland im konkreten
von der stadt leipzig und das ist auch
ein ansatz der vielleicht flächendeckend
auch von interesse sein könnte die stadt
leipzig ist glaube ich nicht viel
kleiner vivendi haben alle einrichtungen
der hammer klinik die home seniorenheime
die homann flughafen die haben alles
mögliche an infrastruktur und dort
besteht die konkrete absicht mit unserem
know how mit unserer expertise
diese weiter zu betreiben und mit
mehreren hunden an der klinik selbst
hier ein forschungsprojekt auf basis
unserer erkenntnisse umzusetzen
die home geld investiert die wollen das
machen die klinik steht dahinter die
politische führung in leipzig steht
dahinter und vor allem gibt es ja dort
keine idealen voraussetzungen wenn die
hundeausbildung direkt an der klinik
stattfindet mit einem konkreten zugang
zu allen materialien die man hier
braucht auch zu den daten der virus
belastung und so weiter und so weiter
weil ohne diese rückmeldungen kann der
hundeführer oder die hundeführerin im
konkreten die dort arbeiten wird ja
nicht wirklich rückschlüsse ziehen das
problem an der erprobung ist bei uns
natürlich gewesen dass man
standardisierte bedingungen für den hund
braucht und diese standardisierten
bedingungen seien zb bei einer
temperatur die über zehn grad sein also
unter zehn grad ist es sehr schwierig
hier diese geruchs partikel auf zu
spüren wo sein einsatz im freien sogar
fast unmöglich macht der wind die
ablenkung und so weiter das heißt man
muss hier entsprechend standardisiert
bedingungen schaffen die ihnen vor allem
zivilen umfeld auch
bereitstellt bar sind
diese prävention für die zukunft es war
für uns von anfang auch ein wichtiger
punkt dass man möglicherweise
zukünftigen bedrohungen mit viren oder
mit ähnlichen
gefährdungen dabei kommen kann wo er
formen der zeit was man kennt es gegeben
hat wichtig jetzt
leipzig hat uns zb in einer
video-konferenz das interesse kundgetan
dass sie nicht nur im bereich corona
hier weiter forschen wollen und weiter
hunde einsetzen wollen sondern unter
anderem ist aus der sicht des klinikums
der sogenannte rc virus der
hauptsächlich kinder befällt zwischen
dem dritten und zwischen dem achten
lebensjahr die dann an der
intensivstation lägen beatmet werden
wenn sie das mitverfolgt haben vorige
wochen hat sie in österreich
medienberichte gegeben dass dieser virus
auch bei uns schon eingetroffen willst
du diese massiv laut aussage der klinik
und die wollen bei dem projekt mit
unserer unterstützung auch diesem rc
virus begegnen wollen was sie noch
machen wollen sind mit bekommen unsere
basis der ausbildung sind gepaart mit
masken der mund nasen schutz sozialer
teilweise hierauf haben wo man natürlich
auch eine zeitverzögerung sie müssen das
zehn minuten büro werden dann kann man
das dem hund vorlegen das kann ich in
einer abgeschlossenen community wo die
leute ganzen masken auf habe ich sogar
meinen seniorenheim im später kann es
sehr gut anwenden auf der straße
irgendwie hat man sogar militärisch zu
kontrollieren der hof in zeitverzug und
das ist doppelt schwierig auch dort will
leipzig
mit unserem wissen und mit unserer
unterstützung sollen auch auf dem auf
der basis strände trainer auf diesem
system von tieren auf speichelproben zu
reflektieren weil mit speichelproben
beziehung mit schweiß proben habe das
ergebnis um den hund an einzusetzen
einsetzen zu können so viel schneller
als mit einer maske dich zehn minuten
partnern muss das ist zum beispiel auch
ein projekt neben dem erforschen des rc
virus wichtig ist dann heute auch diese
schnell schneeballsystem wenn sie sich
vorstellen wir haben in österreich
ungefähr 1000 rettungshunde ausgebildete
1000 ja in deutschland csu weil das
thema so groß wie wir
sollte man vielleicht im hinterkopf
behalten wenn es in der zukunft weiter
eine so große bedrohung ist dass man das
auch auf den zivilen bereich aus holt
also die partner des bundesheeres santo
in jedem fall hundertprozentig dabei am
18 november in kaisersteinbruch das
erste körperliche treffen mit den
vertretern aus leipzig auch mit der
hundetrainerin die das dort machen wird
du willst so entsprechende einweisung
geben der herr professor kaufte das
wissenschaftlich begleitet hat der auch
die wissenschaftliche studie verfasst
hat die wird die ddr keine noch
versprechen wird wird dort auch dabei
sein und wenn diese studie dann einmal
in der öffentlichkeit ist bin ich sicher
dass da ja genügend auf uns zukommt wo
das bundesheer dann auch weiter die sich
wichtige projekt unterstützen wird
dankeschön dankeschön bitte er oberst dr
kleiner
sie haben mich mehr oder weniger gefragt
wie der wert sein könnte und ich darf
der coach ein bisschen ergänzen wir
haben den abschlussbericht durch das
militär hundezentrum bekommen dieser ist
wie gesagt sehr positiv und zudem werden
wir versuchen entsprechend
populärwissenschaftlich in verschiedenen
magazinen die die breite öffentlichkeit
erreichen anzubieten dadurch soll die
bereitschaft des bundesheeres auch
publiziert werden dass wir unser wissen
gerne weitergeben würden und so einen
gesamtstaatlichen
nutzen aus dieser sache ziehen lassen
können
die kooperation gesagt hat sind die
mannen des militär zentrums ja nicht
zahlenmäßig nicht in der lage ganz
österreich auf kobe zu testen sondern
das müsste dann in entsprechender form
in der zivilen seite verankert werden
angesprochen ist auch wissenschaftliche
bericht von professor kafka und was
kopitzsch diesen wollen wir in einem
entsprechenden fachmagazin publizieren
es ist hier vor allem ein
deutschsprachiger beitrag gedacht und
wir werden sehen es ist nicht ganz so
einfach diese artikel sehr rasch zu
publizieren aber wir sollten in einem
zeitraum von etwa in einem halben jahr
das geschafft haben dass ein
entsprechendes fachmagazin diesen
artikel auch akzeptiert also sie sehen
ich glaube dass wir hier wirklich
wegbereiter für möglichkeiten sind um
pandemien ganz allgemein ein zu themen
und die erreger zu erkennen danke sehr
herzlichen dank ich darf nun und wir
fragen versuchen vielleicht im kurzen
handzeichen dass das mikrofon dann zu
ihnen kommen kann bitte
mich hat interessiert wie genau die
ausbildung der hunde abläuft vielleicht
kann man ein bissel umreißt nun wie
lange das dauert bis der hund quasi in
der lage dazu ist eingesetzt zu werden
die ausbildung selbst
ist natürlich abhängig davon wie viel
vor ausbildung und welche basis der
eingesetzte hund hat wir haben im
konkreten hier einen hund eingesetzt ja
schon ein anzeigeverhalten nicht zum
aufspüren von coach und dann ein
allgemeines anzeigeverhalten gekonnt hat
der hund musste wusste was gegenstände
anzeigen zum beispiel betrifft dann wird
der hund grund konditioniert auf den
geruch mit dem nachbarhof die systematik
kennen sie die clique konditionierung
nach bahnhof und dar und ist dann in der
lage in etwa nach zwei wochen geruchs
kennung den entsprechenden stoff
anzuzeigen alles weitere also ich sage
mal es dauert dann sicher ungefähr drei
monate das ist auch die dauer unserer
ausbildungskurse im hundezentrum für
sprengstoffen zugriff zb die mit der
gleichen methode
konditioniert und und ausgebildet werden
damit der hund routine bekommt ja
ablenkung lernen immer die gleiche
situation dass der hund braucht dann
entsprechende routine um hier das
anzuzeigen aber grundsätzlich weiß der
hund ein vor ausgebildet dann noch zwei
wochen wonach er suchen soll
bitte um weitere fragen bietet
sich gegen habe ich das richtig
verstanden dass gesetzt keinen
unmittelbaren corona spürhund einsatz in
in österreich gibt bzw ist so was
geplant ist es noch möglich dass zum
beispiel in den institutionen die diese
angeführt haben umzusetzen und die
zweite frage ist wie heißt der zweite
und der ausgebildet
mit der zweiten hälfte
ja kann ich ihnen sagen der zweite ist
ein rottweiler und der hund heißt hat es
ja der ist dann doch zwei monaten dazu
gestoßen wo wir wie gesagt auch versucht
haben einen rottweiler entsprechend in
diese richtung auszubilden und wie
gesagt es ist auch gelungen wir wissen
jetzt mittlerweile auch welche art von
von 100 charakter dafür notwendig ist
wir brauchen schon hunde die drehbücher
und aktiv sein aber die auf den seiten
doch einen ruhigen charakter haben um
hier auch über längere zeiträume ruhig
suchen zu können ich habe vorher schon
kurz erwähnt frau bundesminister wir
sind eine bildungseinrichtung wir bilden
hunde aus und wenn wir mit dem system
trainer trainer trennte trainer da
irgendwas beitragen können und wenn uns
dinge heran kommen dann werden wir das
tun
außerdem muss man überhaupt einmal
schauen wie sich die pandemie
weiterentwickelt aber ich glaube diese
diese konkrete dieses konkrete
pilotprojekt mit der stadt leipzig ist
ja ein guter startschuss wo ich meine
dass wenn die studie draußen ist auch
das interesse größer werden will
vielleicht ergänzend zum herrn oberster
cockpit das ist wir sind auf diesem
gebiet schon pioniere gewesen das muss
man tatsächlich auch so sagen unter das
system diese wissenschaftlichen
erfahrungswerte die hier gemeinsam mit
den universitäten profis auch getroffen
worden sind und jetzt in dieser studie
publiziert werden sollen sehr vielen
anderen eben nicht nur national sondern
international zur verfügung gestellt
werden es ist nicht unsere aufgabe die
einsätze damit abzudecken das wäre
wahrscheinlich auch nicht besonders
sinnvoll mit der zum einen einmal mit
dem jetzigen stand auch der pandemie und
zum anderen auch mit den zahlreichen
testmöglichkeiten die es auch gibt aber
es gibt sehr wohl einsatzgebiete und wir
haben gesehen dass internationale ebenda
von der stadt leipzig vor der
publizierung bereits dieses interesse da
ist es sind alte wir auch angesprochen
worden wo man vielleicht auch einen
zusätzlichen nutzen noch generieren kann
und ich kann ja noch einmal sagen ich
bin wirklich stolz auf diese
pionierleistung wie hier von den
soldatinnen soldaten auch getätigt
worden ist
bitte um weitere fragen
wenn es keine weiteren fragen gibt dann
sage ich herzlichen dank für kommen und
behinderte presse-konferenz dankeschön
dankeschön